garbeck video ich schwanke immer so ein
bisschen zwischen faszination und
fassungslosigkeit wenn ich sowas hier
sehe und sich das dann auch noch
millionen leute anschauen obwohl die
sachen die da gezeigt werden überhaupt
nicht funktioniert also schauen wir mal
was das internet uns heute zu bieten hat
das anker aus dem wurzelwerk team reist
du da bist was macht sogar kurze werk ja
ich bin gemüsegarten total wurzelwerk
und wenn leute fragen haben rund um die
gemüse garten darf es ruhig da kannst du
zu helfen sie kennt sich aus naja
bin gespannt
wer eine flasche die mit erde gefüllt
ist und einen mini spaten der löcher in
plastikflaschen rein machen kann sehr
interessant und
da kommen jetzt anscheinend zwiebeln
rein ich kann mir schon vorstellen
worauf das hinausläuft
genauer die treiben dann aus logisch und
dann kann man das zwiebel grünen ernten
aber in dem fall dass jetzt kein richtig
schlimmer hätte aber in dem fall will
ich wie er frühlingszwiebeln sehen oder
eben steck zwiebeln stecken und nicht
der richtige küchen zwiebeln die man ja
an sich noch hätte essen können weil das
eigentlich für die zwiebel verschwendung
ist aber an sich ist das auf jeden fall
ein hack der funktioniert dabei es ist
ja auch erst der erste gucken was auf
platz zehn
aber ja was mit kamillentee wie schön ok
also überbrühen und
machen wir mal kurz stopp
[Applaus]
einer der absurdesten heck die ich
bisher gesehen habe
und das spannende ist also von meinem
gefühl würde ich sagen das ist auch
keine camino de das sieht aus wie auf
jeden fall kürbisgewächse brücke
vielleicht oder
sollten wir immer kam endlich auf
gruppen sagen ja vielleicht du bist du
dazu muss man wissen dass erstens nicht
gleich ob in so einem säckinger melde
überhaupt samen enthalten sind weil
normalerweise die blüten geerntet werden
bevor sie samen ausgebildet haben dann
würden wenn der samen enthalten werden
beim kochen wenn man sich den tee
zubereitet erstmal schön abgetötet dh
aus diesen beiden gründen kann das schon
mal eigentlich gar nicht funktionieren
und dann ist die kamera und licht käme
hier wird sie in der erde vergraben
eigentlich streut man die samen oben auf
die erde auf also gleich drei riesen
große schnitzer in seinem video und
trotzdem gucken sich das millionen
weiter an und machen das zuhause nach
das ist einfach traurig sicher keine
kamelle die herausgekommen ist okay was
haben wir hier eine luftbrücke die wird
aufgeschnitten lucha gute hände von
innen aus und dann war man drin im
garten helga volk einfach die sachen aus
der gurke genommen und hält diese ist
nicht so dass menschen das seit
tausenden von jahren machen werden ok
topic ich bin gespannt auf die nächste
das sieht interessant aus wir haben eine
große wassermelone so schneidig die bei
mir zu hause auch immer auf der hut hast
du die kreissäge gesehen
und ich kann mir auch hier vorstellen
worauf das hinauslaufen wird okay die
wird jetzt mit erde befüllt und ich
denke mal die wollen die als an sucht
gesetz oder blumentopf verwenden glaubst
du das funktioniert also ich hatte ein
bisschen angst alles und schimmelt
leute macht es nicht das ist wirklich
eklig wenn das ganze anfängt zu
schimmeln denkmal vor diese wassermelone
die sieht vielleicht drei tage so frisch
aus und danach fängt die natürlich an zu
verrotten next holen
da kommt klopapier drauf oder
krepppapier und da kommen dann caprica
samen drauf wie denn das machen okay das
ganze nennt sich vor keimen das mache
ich auch ganz gerne ist an sich eine
coole sache vielleicht ein bisschen
aufwändig wie das hier gemacht ist
gemacht dass in plastiktütchen
okay das sind erstens keine paprika die
daraus wachsen wenn zweitens macht man
das vor keimen eigentlich nur einen ganz
kurzen zeitraum bis die allerersten
keine spitzen aus den samen rausschauen
und dann setzt man die in erde um weil
pflanzen gerne in erde wachsen und hier
im wasserglas haben sie ja gar keine
nährstoffe wenn man die jungen
pflänzchen so aufzieht ergibt es einfach
gar keinen sinn
sie einfach einen viel schlechteren
start in ihre pflanzen leben als wenn
man diese ganz normal einfach in die
erde legen würde so in einem wasserglas
ein bisschen klopapier ja auch das kann
er und biete durchgeschnitten ja das ist
so ziemlich der typische gartenhecke
denke ich mal die wird jetzt in wasser
gelegt und dann treibt rote beete grün
aus das funktioniert auch ich habe schon
mal so ein ähnliches video wie das hier
gemacht und auch ganz viele verrückte
garten hacks reagiert bzw die dann sogar
zu hause bei mir nach gemacht wenn ihr
das nicht kennt dann schaut es auf jeden
fall mal an also das funktioniert das
haben wir auch ausprobiert aber man muss
dazu sagen ich würde die rote beete
niemals einfach so in der hälfte
durchschneiden und dann kann man ein
hälfte davon verwenden also das ist
schon eine riesengroße
lebensmittelverschwendung dafür dass man
nur das rote beete grün bekommt als
nachwächst weil die rote beete selber
wird nicht mehr nachwachsen und die kann
man dann am ende auch nicht mehr essen
weil das ziemlich schnell ziemlich eklig
wird so dass man sozusagen eine halbe
rote beete opfert um am ende ein
bisschen rote beete grün zu bekommen
nicht so der beste deal in meinen augen
aber okay es funktioniert auf jeden fall
dass ihr der spannend aus ja
die paprika oder krieg das ist ne
man warte so auch das resultat oder
yahoo mit programmen im topf das war
schon oder was
eine mutation auf anja schimmelpilz
mutation
der hüter häckermann schimmelpilze
anbauen möchte keine ahnung was man
damit aussagen möchte falls es jemand
von euch versteht sagt es gerne wenn ihr
ideen habt ich würde gern mal sehen wie
das aussieht wenn man das drei wochen
auf der fensterbank stehen
weiter gehts jetzt kommt der kürbis der
wird aufgeschnitten
da kommen die
zusammen
bzw da kommt er da auf die samen drauf
und dann wachsen die daraus ok erstmal
ja es wird wahrscheinlich
funktionierende es ist aber wieder eine
große lebensmittelverschwendung also ich
würde diese haben da einfach raus nehmen
den der kronprinzessin und ihr das
samenkorn in den einzelnen köpfchen
stecken damit meinen die später nur noch
einmal um pflanzen muss im garten raus
ja genau dazu kommt dass kürbisse
überhaupt nicht gerne umgepflanzt werden
deswegen sieht man kürbisse und gurken
eigentlich auch immer gleich direkt in
so ein großes töpfchen damit die bis sie
dann nach draußen ins beet wandern nicht
noch mal in ein anderes töpfchen
umgepflanzt werden müssen wenn hier so
viele kürbisse dann daraus auf die ihn
dann muss man ja die einzelnen
pflänzchen vereinzeln deswegen mache das
auf jeden fall nicht so das geht viel
viel einfacher und viel weniger eklig
wenn wir das ganz normal macht so wie
man halt kürbisse zählt da haben wir
eine huawei die wird aufgeschnitten
ringscheibe rausgeschnitten
da sind samen drin die kombiniert okay
das ist mal wieder
lebensmittelverschwendung haben wäre es
glaube ich schon oft gehabt diesen fall
warum nicht einfach die frucht essen und
die samen einzeln in die erde geben es
tut den samen nicht so gut wenn da noch
so viel organisches material um sie drum
herum ist während sie versuchen auf zu
gehen und vor allem ja auch das ist ein
kleiner kreis das und irgendwie ganzen
samen und dann werden die rauskommen
kommt ja viel zu dicht beieinander jetzt
kommt ein zucker maiskolben in einen
topf mit erde und das sind bleibt auch
okay ich weiß
ja also bei mainz ist eigentlich dass
man körnchen harz und in den boden und
da kommt eine jungpflanze raus aber das
hat bei mir noch nie so ausgesehen
vor allem das ist immer besonders lustig
wenn ich sowas sehe weil zucker mais
nämlich unreif geerntet wird wenn die
kerne noch weich sind wollt ihr mal
sehen wie ein reifer maiskolben aussieht
der so richtig hat der ist aus greift
der ist nicht mehr so weit wie so ein
zucker meister das bedeutet dass aus so
einem weichen zucker maiskolben hier
niemals pflanzen raus wachsen werden
weil die samen einfach noch nicht so
weit sind dass sie über babys machen
können die sind noch nicht mal der
pubertät
also ich muss sagen dass ich das ganze
schon relativ unterhaltsam finde aber
ein bisschen traurig wenn ich weiß dass
das super viele menschen anschauen die
nicht wissen das ist bullshit ist sorry
jetzt musste ich mal fluchen hier auf
meinem super familienfreundlichen kanal
man aber das ist doch einfach also kein
guter test in zucker meist wenn ihr lust
auf ein paar gartenhecke habt die
richtig cool sind und die wirklich
funktionieren dann schaut gerne da
drüben vorbei und wenn ihr sehen wollt
wie ich ein paar von diesen verrückten
internet garten hacks ausprobieren dann
gerne da unten ansonsten geht raus macht
die welt ein bisschen grüner und wir
sehen uns am samstag um 10 für ein neues
video teams